In chapter 907 of One Piece, we first learn
about an infamous pirate called Rocks D. Xebec.
Since that chapter, we’ve learned that he
not only tried to take over the world, but
he was also the captain of a crew that included
three future Emperors.
So in this video, we are going to explain
everything that we know for a fact, all the
hints about his past, and even some incredible
speculations about his true purpose in the
story.
Now since we really don’t know a whole lot
about Rocks, it is important to clearly explain
what is fact, or close to fact, and what is
speculation.
To do that we are going to break up the information
about Rocks into six categories and in each
category discuss what we know and what we
can speculate.
Starting with a brief introduction.
In chapter 907, Luffy’s grandfather Garp
first revealed that the Rocks pirates ruled
the seas forty years ago, which is about fourteen
years before Gol D. Roger became the pirate
king.
Garp tells a group of marines that if the
Rocks pirates were to reform then they would
be a threat beyond what any of them could
imagine.
Fifty chapters later, the former fleet admiral
Sengoku reveals a boatload more about Rocks
and his insane crew.
We learned that the World Government considered
Rocks to be their biggest threat and it took
an unbelievable effort to stop him from taking
over the world, which we’ll discuss more
later on.
So let’s dive into what was probably the
strongest pirate crew ever.
Here are the facts.
On this ridiculous crew were three future
Emperors of the Sea: The strongest creature
in the world, Kaido, the monstrous mother
Big Mom, and former strongest man in the world,
Whitebeard.
Besides these three powerhouses, we have Shiki,
who was a former rival of Roger’s.
In addition, this old lady, Miss Bakkin, was
part of the crew before she joined the science
group, MADS.
Then we have Silver Axe, who is a complete
mystery.
Captain John, who had a famous treasure, died,
and then unfortunately got turned into a zombie
on Thriller Ba.
And finally there was Wang Zhi, also known
as Ochoku.
While we don’t know a lot about Ochoku,
we do know he ruled over the Rocks’ pirates
former base island.
And we cannot mention a pirate crew without
discussing their sh.
While we don’t have any other information
about it, you can see that it is a large vessel
and pretty damn intimidating.
Now, let’s shift to discussing the relationships
of this wild crew because it is unlike anything
we have seen in the story.
In chapter 957, Sengoku revealed that the
crew’s dynamic was horribly toxic.
The crew members would regularly fight and
even kill each other.
But what is even more interesting is what
we can speculate about the crew’s relationships
from other clues sprinkled throughout the
story.
First, Whitebeard seemed to have a very negative
experience on Rocks’ crew.
His reaction was kinda like a boss you hate
to work for.
In chapter 964, Whitebeard initially refuses
to let the samurai Oden join his crew because
Whitebeard had a bad experience with his own
previous crew, which was most likely the Rocks
pirates.
From this we can assume that he has a lot
of resentment from his time on Rocks’ crew
since it is still bothering him decades later.
He must have learned that having too many
strong willed personalities can destroy a
crew.
This supports Sengoku’s claims that the
crew was in a state of near constant chaos.
Another fact is that Big Mom did not trust
Rocks at all.
In chapter 1041 during a flashback, we see
that Kaido has just joined the Rocks crew.
And Big Mom tells Kaido that if he needed
anything, he should count on her because Rocks
was not trustworthy.
From this, it seems that Rocks did not lead
by inspiring trust and loyalty, as it seems
that many of them did not even like him at
all.
And this mistrust had the ultimate consequence
for Rocks, when the crew later abandoned him
as we’ll discuss later on.
If this is true, then we have to wonder how
exactly Rocks kept this crazy crew together.
Let’s shift over and dive into everything
we know about Rocks D. Xebec as a person as
well as his powers and history.
Of course, starting with the fact that he
is dead… **coughs** maybe.
Even though Sengoku tells us that Rocks is
dead, the circumstances of his mysterious
disappearance make me believe that this is
not all we have seen from such an important
character.
And let’s compare this situation to an equally
famous dead pirate.
The execution of Roger is the first scene
in the entire story, and while we don’t
learn a lot more about Roger until much later
on, his influence is present all throughout
the story.
From his former crew mates, his rivals, and
even the fact that we found clues about his
journey along the way.
But while Rocks was pretty much an equally
powerful and influential figure, we did not
learn anything about him for over 900 chapters.
So it makes me think that one, he is either
still alive and going to play a role in the
story, or two, he is dead, but we will get
a huge reveal about his past in the upcoming
arcs.
Previously on this channel we have even discussed
the possibility that he might have been Luffy’s
other Grandfather, or another theory by the
creator Artur speculates that he could actually
be the secret ruler of the world, Imu.
Taking over the world was Rocks’ goal in
the first place and these two characters were
introduced so close together in the story.
But whether he is dead or alive, we can reasonably
assume that he was evil.
We know that Garp and Roger, both of whom
are “good” characters, tried to stop him
from achieving his goals.
Also, Whitebeard clearly didn’t like him
and the World Government considered the Rocks
Pirates terrorists.
So whatever his true intentions were, it is
likely that he committed terrible acts in
the pursuit of his dreams.
And what were his dreams?
Well, we are told by Sengoku that Rocks was
ambitious and his dream was to be King of
the World.
And damn that’s a title we have basically
never heard anyone use before.
Not only did he want to become pirate king
like Luffy, it seems he truly wanted to dominate
and rule over everyone.
And he almost succeeded, which we will discuss
during his final battle later on.
This leads to another interesting question,
can someone be king of the world without being
insanely powerful?
We know that it took both Roger and Garp teaming
up to defeat Rocks, and he was considered
the former pirate kings’ greatest rival.
So clearly he was a strong fighter.
We know that Rocks used a sword, as we are
shown in this scene.
Even Kaido considered Rocks to be one of the
few pirates who could give him a challenge.
And since we also know that Kaido, Big Mom,
and Whitebeard all had conqueror’s haki,
it makes sense that their former captain would
as well.
This is speculation, but his conqueror’s
haki could also have been on another level,
since he commanded them.
This is further supported because his main
goal was to be king of the world.
And if that’s not legendary conqueror’s
spirit, then I don’t know what is.
One thing we have no details about is if Rocks
had a devil fruit.
There is no mention of such powers, so it
is possible he did not have a devil fruit,
similar to Roger and Garp.
Or he might have had one and we just haven’t
been told yet.
Another possibility that we can speculate
is that Rocks was patiently waiting to get
the right fruit – sound like anyone familiar
– and that Rocks was finally going to get
that devil fruit during the legendary battle
we will discuss in a moment.
And alongside his powers, Rocks was deeply
curious about history.
Sengoku tells us that he broke many of the
world’s taboos and that he was erased from
history because of it.
This must mean that he was researching the
poneglyphs, which are these unbreakable stones
that tell the history of the void century.
Throughout the story, researching the poneglyphs
is the only reason the world government has
erased a group of people, such as on the island
of Ohara and as they are trying to do to the
government scientist, Dr. Vegapunk, in the
current arc.
And this allows us to speculate that either
Rocks himself could read the poneglyphs or
that he knew someone who could.
This idea opens a whole new avenue for theories.
For example, one interesting theory centers
around the mysterious three-eyed tribe which
was first mentioned in chapter 853.
During the whole cake island arc, we meet
Big Mom’s daughter, Pudding.
She was born with a third eye, meaning that
her father must have been from the three-eyed
tribe.
According to Big Mom, people from this tribe
naturally possess the ability to use the Voice
of All Things.
Though in Pudding’s case, she has not awakened
the power yet.
This mysterious power allows certain people
to hear the thoughts of animals such as the
sea kings and even vaguely understand the
words on the poneglyphs.
But how does Big Mom know about this tribe
in the first place?
These are all speculation, but a simple, though
unlikely answer, is that she could have randomly
found them on an island somewhere in the world.
But we have never seen this tribe anywhere
and very few people seem to know they exist.
Another possibility is that Rocks himself
was from the three eye tribe or that he had
someone on the crew who was.
This would explain how he could research the
history of the void century since only two
people are confirmed to be able to read the
poneglyphs.
Kaido also knows of the secret ability of
the three eye tribe, so he could have also
learned it from Rocks.
It would also make sense that they learned
about the poneglyphs from Rocks, since we
are never told that either of them traveled
to Lodestar island.
In chapter 820, we are told that it is on
Lodestar that a person is supposed to first
learn about the poneglyphs.
But moving back to some facts, Rocks was also
a member of the D clan.
People who have this initial, such as Luffy,
Blackbeard, and Dragon, are said to be the
enemies of the celestial dragons.
It would make sense then that he was also
likely a charismatic leader, similar to Luffy,
and he somehow convinced all of these strong
pirates to come together to make one big score.
And that one big score seems to be taking
out the celestial dragons on the legendary
island, God Valley.
And you can also land one big score by subscribing
to the channel to receive more videos just
like this one.
So let’s finally discuss what happened in
the legendary battle on God Valley where Rocks
was defeated.
First, we know that 38 years ago the Rocks
pirates attacked a mysterious island called
God Valley.
This event has been covered up by the World
Government because basically no one knows
about it, except for people who were there
or older marines.
Part of the reason it was covered up is the
fact that Rocks could only be stopped by an
alliance between a much younger Garp and Roger
before he became pirate king.
And what a clash it must have been.
Rocks.
Roger.
Whitebeard.
Garp.
Big Mom.
Kaido.
**praying hands** Please Oda-sensei, show
us more of this legendary fight.
And while we know next to nothing about the
actual battle or the island itself – which
has vanished – we are told that Garp and
Roger defended the celestial dragons and their
slaves who were on the island.
But part of this does not make any sense.
You see, we know that Garp hates the celestial
dragons and he has even refused to become
an admiral because he doesn’t want to take
orders from them.
So we have to wonder why he and Roger saved
the celestial dragons on God Valley.
There are a few options, and the last one
will completely blow your mind.
But first, the easiest possibility is that
Garp simply protected the slaves on God Valley.
Certainly that would fit with Garp’s character.
Another option that I’ve theorized in a
separate video, is that Garp, Roger, and Rocks
were all once on a crew together before Rocks
went power-crazy.
So perhaps Garp and Roger felt it was their
duty to stop Rocks before he did something
insanely evil.
And the final option was that there was something
else on God Valley that Garp and Roger could
not allow Rocks to take.
But what could this magical treasure be?
**Pause** Uhh, maybe, but no.
In all seriousness, it is actually highly
plausible that the world government’s devil
fruits were kept on God Valley and this is
what Rocks Rocks was after all along.
We go into full detail of this theory in my
Best Rocks D. Xebec Theory video, but let’s
briefly discuss the topic here.
Devil fruits are the source of the magical
powers in the One Piece world, so obviously
they are incredibly valuable.
We know that the world government likes to
gather devil fruits, such as the Opi-Opi no
Mi, and that government agents can sometimes
get strong devil fruits such as when these
two secret agents were given their fruits
in Enies Lobby.
So what if they have a large store of devil
fruits or even a devil fruit tree that used
to be on God Valley.
And while this is a theory, there is some
evidence to support it.
For example, in chapter 999 Big Mom reminds
Kaido that she gave him his legendary devil
fruit ON THE SAME DAY as the battle on God
Valley when the Rocks pirates fell to ruin.
What if she found it on God Valley during
the chaos of the battle?
Similarly, we do not know where Whitebeard
got his legendary Tremor fruit, which is said
to be capable of destroying islands.
We never see him use it until after the God
Valley incident, so what if he also found
his fruit during the battle.
And remember how we said that Rocks’ toxic
crew dynamic would come back to bite him.
Well, it is interesting to see that every
member of Rocks’ crew abandoned him at God
Valley.
What if this crew, who didn’t really care
about their captain, got their strong devil
fruits and then just left.
It also goes along with the idea that the
Rocks crew was formed to make one big score.
So once they had their own powerful devil
fruits, the crew didn’t care to stick around.
If all this is true, we have to imagine that
Rocks was after his own strong devil fruit
so that he could take over the world.
And I know we are super deep into theory territory
here, but let me make one last connection
before we get back to things that we know.
If Rocks was seeking a devil fruit to help
him conqueror the world, wouldn’t it make
sense that he would want the strongest one
possible.
Well, we are told that many people consider
a certain devil fruit to be the most dangerous
ability in history.
And that is the darkness fruit which was eaten
by Blackbeard.
What if Rocks was seeking this fruit on God
Valley and he didn’t fail, but that he actually
got the fruit out into the world before he
died or disappeared forever.
And now let’s shift to Blackbeard, because
out of any character in the story he has the
most direct connection to Rocks.
Here are the facts.
Blackbeard named his ship the Saber of Xebec,
a clear reference to Rocks D. Xebec.
The two pirates also appear to have the same
method of building crews based solely on strength.
For example, Blackbeard gathered a large part
of his crew by having prisoners fight to the
death and then only taking the strongest survivors.
And Rocks’ crew was well known to fight
each other.
Also, both crews seem to have a large number
of devil fruit users.
Blackbeard has ensured that most members of
his crew have a devil fruit.
With Rocks’ crew, we don’t know if all
of them had devil fruits, but Whitebeard,
Kaido, and Big Mom all eventually got over
powerful devil fruits.
Blackbeard also cares a lot about dreams and
wants to conquer the world just like Rocks.
They also are the only members of the D clan
who appear to be outright evil.
Even their smiles are eerily similar.
They also both made this island their home
base.
This island has many names including Beehive,
Hachinosu, or simply Pirate Island.
This is where the Rocks pirates were formed,
and after the crew disbanded it was taken
over by the former Rocks pirate, Ochoku.
He was ruling Hachinosu until Blackbeard claimed
the island during the time skip.
This incident also involved marine vice-admiral
Koby and was called the Rocky Port Incident.
And while we don’t know Ochoku’s exact
powers, he must have been strong because Blackbeard
said that he only was able to overthrow Ochoku
due to the assistance of Luffy’s friend
and marine Vice-admiral Koby during the Rocky
Port Incident.
And Blackbeard hasn’t changed much since
he took over the island.
With partying and drinking all around, it
is truly a lawless pirate paradise.
And while Blackbeard currently rules this
island, there is some room to theorize that
Buggy the Clown may eventually make an appearance
on the island.
How, you ask?
Well remember that Buggy has long been chasing
the treasure of the former Rocks’ pirate,
Captain John.
In chapter 233, we see Buggy searching for
the treasure on an island with an enormous
skull.
While this turned out to be the wrong island
with a giant skull, Hachinosu also has this
giant skull.
So wouldn’t it make sense that Captain John’s
treasure was still on the island of the former
Rocks pirates?
This could eventually lead Buggy to this island.
And who knows, maybe at the end of the story,
this could be Buggy’s home base.
But enough of Buggy, let’s get back to Blackbeard.
With all of the connections between Blackbeard
and Rocks, let’s explore this relationship
a bit further.
We already discussed how Rocks could have
previously wanted Blackbeard’s devil fruit.
A common theory within the community is that
Rocks actually ate the Darkness fruit and
his soul is still living inside of the fruit.
Now before you call me crazy, let me explain.
The Darkness fruit is said to be a strange
fruit compared to every other devil fruit.
It doesn’t work like a typical Logia fruit,
as it absorbs all attacks, instead of being
unaffected by common attacks.
Also, one of the main powers we see Blackbeard
use is to suck everything into a Black Hole
. If it can suck in people and buildings,
it isn’t that much of a stretch to think
it could also contain a soul.
So could Blackbeard actually have a piece
of Rocks inside of him?
There is some evidence that it could be possible.
We have multiple references of Blackbeard
possibly being multiple people.
Marco the Phoenix claims that he has a weird
body which might be the reason he was able
to eat two devil fruits.
Luffy and Zoro mention that he could be more
than one person.
And after a battle, apprentices Buggy the
Clown and Shanks discuss how Blackbeard is
rumored to never sleep although this occurred
before Blackbeard obtained his Darkness fruit.
This could mean that he has multiple personalities
that come awake while the other or others
sleep.
Whether this is true or not, there is certainly
some connection between the two.
It could be that Blackbeard is somehow related
to Rocks, as Blackbeard was born two years
before the God Valley incident.
Another option is that Blackbeard inherited
Rocks’ will after reading a journal or something
left behind by Rocks, and Blackbeard to achieve
Rocks’ dream sometime in the near future.
And speaking of the future, Rocks’ influence
will undoubtedly impact the story later on.
If he is still alive, he will surely show
up to be an obstacle for the straw hats.
Or if he is dead, we could learn more about
him from many different characters.
The upper tier marines like Garp, Sengoku,
or the Commander in Chief, Kong, should certainly
know about him.
Shanks and the other Roger pirates could know
about Rocks as well.
And certainly Big Mom and Kaido know about
him, if they are still alive.
The five Elders and Imu should also know exactly
what happened to Rocks, and even Buggy, if
he were to find Captain John’s treasure,
could discover clues about this mysterious
figure.
And I can imagine that at the same time we
find out more about Rocks D. Xebec, we will
find out even more information about the most
mysterious and influential character in the
series: Joy Boy.
Much like Luffy and Blackbeard are basically
opposites, the Joy Boy from the Void Century
and Rocks appear to have opposing roles in
the story.
Joy Boy brings liberation while Rocks wants
to conqueror and rule the world.
And this insane connection will undoubtedly
influence the future of the story.
So, who is Joy Boy and what do we know about
this figure from the Void Century?
If you want to find out, you can watch this
video right here.
Shanks for watching.